[Music]
[Applause]
brand new protest says the media in the
far left Democrats fan the Flames over a
Subway Chokehold death here in New York
City a grand jury is expected to meet
next week to determine if there should
be criminal charges filed against the
Marine who restrained 30-year-old Jordan
Neely it happened after Witnesses say
the homeless man started yelling and
threatening passengers police sources
telling the New York Post that five
emergency calls were made over a
four-minute span the first two
referencing a physical altercation and
someone threatening passengers
new video shows more of what happened
Neely struggles with the marine and two
other Riders who are telling people to
call the police before Neely passes out
well Democrats push murder charges New
York city mayor Eric Adams is urging
caution because the facts may change
Adam's busting the narrative that the
Chokehold lasted 15 minutes listen
I ask you get the body Cam and I
realized that they were there in six
minutes
and I said well what did the 15 minutes
come from you know someone bloated it
out and all of a sudden it became the
facts and so we have to be very careful
that facts is based on the actual facts
and not what we want to create them to
be I just want to be clear did not take
police officers 15 minutes to get there
when I first read that I was that was
too bizarre to me but Democrats in the
liberal press don't care about the
mayor's warning they've already rushed
to judgment
I couldn't help but think of the like 10
other things that could have been done
before this person decided to wrap his
arms around Mr Neely's neck and choke
him to death he can't say self-defense
he was not at risk so to let this go
forward in any way is to sanction
vigilantism he's an ex-marine but he's
an ex-marine who is trained to kill
there should be charges that are put out
there and I think it's because who was
killed that hasn't happened
you were off yesterday we missed you and
now you've had what 48 hours to digest
this tragedy where do you see things
moving
first of all this is a very sad case I
think that a lot of people are
responsible uh or one of the most
significant is the mental health system
in New York State uh this is a guy who
was a schizophrenic I believe he was
probably in the midst of an episode when
you're in the midst of an episode uh you
can be extremely violent now we don't
know if that's the case and I'm not
suggesting it's the case we don't know
all the facts so unless and until it is
resolved by a grand jury we can't make a
decision look this Marine is entitled to
use whatever force is necessary to
prevent an individual from committing or
using that Force against another person
I mean all these people these Talking
Heads they don't know what the hell
they're talking about they don't know
the law they make it up as they go along
you know the people like Joy Reid saying
ridiculous things like the other people
watching how is that not a crime they
should be charged with a crime I mean
that's all nonsense we have a law in New
York state and it's very clear if A call
came in saying that he was threatening
and harassing passengers if he was in
the midst of a psychotic episode if
indeed this person was reasonable in his
mind the marine and the the facts make
it clear not just before but after where
they leave him in a recovery position
they didn't leave him in a position
where he was on his back and could have
choked they left him in a recovery
position he did move after they let him
go what they were saying where are the
police he waited for the police well
it's not a black versus white because it
was a black guy who was holding him down
as well so there are subjective and
objective tests that will be used this
is a guy who's been arrested 40
sometimes he he knocked some 67 year old
woman out you know he he was a mess and
by the way when you say it don't have
food I'm fed up I don't mind getting
life in prison I'm ready to die and
you're threatening people that kind of
sends his signal that this guy can be
dangerous so let's everybody like pipe
down a little bit and and hocal the
governor what an embarrassment this
woman is people shouldn't be killed for
being a passenger on a subway and for
all those people who are out there
protesting 27 people have died in the
last two years on the subway where were
you I think we have some of that hocal
sound let's listen
I do want to acknowledge how horrific it
was to view a video of Jordan Neely
being killed for being a passenger on
our subway trains and so our hearts go
out to his families I'm really pleased
that the district attorney is looking
into this matter as I said there had to
be consequences and so we'll see how
this unfolds but uh his family deserves
Justice
it's a pretty reckless thing to say as
you know you're the governor
it's going to be back the this is the
herald this is a terrible story I agree
with the judge
um he was a passenger but there was
something else going on there it seems I
want to get all of the facts I agree
with the judge we do know that New York
law is clear around this that any
response to a real or perceived threat
has to be proportionate to the threat
and if he believed in his mind that this
threat was of a of a nature and a level
that he needed to respond that way uh
then the law will be be applied
appropriately I think those in the city
who believe that crime is going down or
that safety Public Safety is increasing
this is a a prime example that it's not
and it's really there's a long list of
politicians who've lost the office who
have told voters that you're richer than
you think you're safer than you think
and the country is more prosperous if
people don't believe that then they're
not going to react accordingly certainly
not in a political setting in this
particular matter here I agree with the
judge we got to wait for the facts I
think mayor Adams his his language and
his conduct should be modeled and
immolated as we as we go forward with
this process and so Alvin Bragg's going
to have this next week or it's going to
go to a grand jury do you think he can
get a fair Shake here in Manhattan I
actually do because you know Harold
touched on this a little bit people
don't have a sense of safety when they
ride the trains here and and I'm looking
at the story and it is tragic you know
it makes me really sad because AOC is
calling this Marina murder but it's like
what about Thrive NYC what about the
billion dollar mental health initiative
that our former mayor's wife was in
charge of and that money is just gone it
evaporated you know why wasn't Jordan
Neely given the help that he needed for
the years and years that he was in the
system you know he was known to
authorities he was known to doctors he
was known to social workers and mental
health care workers and you know his
grandmother said the system failed him
so it wasn't just this one instance and
that is tragic because the layers of
bureaucracy that are developed by big
government actually put people like him
at risk and they don't help him and she
game on AOC for representing this part
of the country and not standing up to
the bureaucracy that got this guy killed
and you know it's like I ride the train
by myself sometimes at night we've all
seen stuff like this happen and my
question is what are you supposed to do
you know it's like I don't feel
comfortable carrying a knife because I
don't want to be in a situation like
this where God forbid there's a struggle
and someone dies and then I'm liable for
it same thing with my daughters I don't
want them carrying weapons but how do
you defend yourself and how do you keep
other people around you safe it's a good
point Greg the left really appreciates
Jordan Neely now that he's dead they
didn't give two F's about him when he
was alive so they do not deserve to be
listened to Al Sharpton says if you are
uh not at risk do nothing and then Joy
Reid says if you don't do something you
should be charged again they do not
deserve to be listened to
um hokel said you know that could be you
assuming that we Society would identify
with an unhinged violent felon threaten
people who've attacked women and
children that could be you no no when
you say that could be you Governor you
should be talking about the bystanders
who are now the target of losers like
you hocal that could be you you could be
the bystander on the train who decided
to share the risk and do something to
save somebody else and you could be the
Target that could be you that's the
story you this is how it works
right the left hamstrings the police and
it creates a vacuum where security used
to be and then when it gets really
really bad the Bernie gets moment the
citizens step in and then they become
the target you saw that with Rittenhouse
and the mccloskeys the goal is to make
that vacuum permanent so this revolution
through chaos burn it all down is
endless no matter what happens right
right Obama got elected burn it all down
right the police improved they start
training they start doing better things
you have a majority minority Force
burning all down doesn't matter in the
minds of the radical left it's always
going to be burned on down now we're
seeing more video of the deceased right
accosting people using homophobic
language F the f word that f word the
n-word right it's strange this beloved
street performer this beloved Michael
Jackson performer is a Relentless Menace
and the media did not want to tell you
he was a Relentless Menace and it was
only going to happen this way this was
not the beginning of the story this was
the end of the story the city had this
problem for years this show a few others
were the canary in the coal mine it
wasn't the view it wasn't AOC hokel
hokel scoffed when we brought up the
crime stuff during the election remember
she said it was played up and now she's
sitting there acting like she's
compassionate shut up it's her
incompetence her inaction that created
this moment in time where young men
young men stepped up and did the job she
was too cowardly to manage or do
all right thank you well said yeah
you're dismissed yeah it's happy hour
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else